I want to bring in from Montreal muang
Rabani he's co-editor of the online news
site Jalia and he's a non-resident
fellow at the center for conflict and
humanitarian studies very good to have
you with us um I want to draw on your
experience as someone who knows a great
deal about conflict resolution with
regard to the delay that we've seen over
the last few hours uh prior to the
Palestinian prisoners and the Israeli
captives being released how from a
contextual point of view How likely is
that to happen is that kind of
really to be expected in a deal like
this well as people who have dealt with
the Israelis will tell you um typical
pattern is that first you negotiate an
agreement and then you have to negotiate
the implementation of what's already
been agreed upon and then they will
nevertheless try to implement what has
already been agreed in a way that best
suits their interest so that's one
aspect a second aspect is that I think
we're also dealing with a test of Wills
here in which the Israelis are trying to
implement the agreement in their way to
show Hamas that they're in control and
in charge and Hamas responded by
delaying the release of captives um to
demonstrate that they won't be
intimidated and that they insist on the
agreement being implemented as um as
concluded uh several days ago so I think
there are several factors and and I have
to say I mean you these are obviously
not minor issues but they're not exactly
the the heart of the substance of this
agreement either and I think that
explains why ultimately it was resolved
after several hours does that I was
going to ask you does that give us an
indication of of the the the speed at
which Qatar and Egypt were able to find
some sort of solution to this um does
that give us an indication of the
significance of of these matters and are
we likely to see more incidents like
this in certain well we have one more
day to go is it likely that in the next
24 hours or so we're going to see a
similar situation where both sides as
you say are kind of like testing the
waters and testing the tolerances of
each
other well there's there's two more days
um and you know the um most of these
issues can be resolved but I mean when
it gets to the point where Israel is
shooting to death refugees attempting to
return to their homes to visit family or
get a change of clothes that's obviously
a very serious matter and another issue
is that there are no monitors on site um
to monitor the proper implementation of
the various uh commitments by the party
so um you know if anyone wants to
sabotage uh this agreement they will
certainly have an opportunity to do so
and then blame it on the other side
given all the um very tough statements
we've seen from Israeli leaders on the
one hand one might think that um uh it
would be in their interest to resume uh
the war and and the offensive as soon as
possible I think another
interpretation is that they're talking
so tough um in order to be able to
justify an extension of the truth by
then claiming that it was their threat
the threats of further military pressure
that compelled uh the pal Palestinians
to agree in extension and here we have
to remember that at the outset of this
war um Israel specifically the Prime
Minister and the defense minister and
the chief of staff made very clear there
would be no negotiations and there would
be no truce and what we have now is a
truce achieved by
negotiations um and so therefore I think
you know they're in a politically um
difficult spot mon Rani we appreciate it
co-editor of online news site Jania
thank you very much
indeed thank you